الان يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع اهلا بك استاذ يوسف على
شاشه العربيه
كيف كيف تتناول او تقرا معنا الاخبار ما
تحدث به احمد هارون في التسجيل الصوتي
والاخبار عن اماكن تواجد قيادات كبرى من
النظام السابق
نعم نحن نتوقع
كلاب الحركه الاسلاميه الذي يدبره على
كرتي نتوقع كل هذا كان لو نجح الانقلاب
قوات التامه السريع لتم اطلاقهم علنا
لاستضافتهم القنوات اللي كان الشعب
السوداني الذي لقده في دوله ديسمبر الان
الضحيه
لعودتهم الى السلطان لكن هذا امر متوقع
ومستفز للشعب السوداني
مجلس السياده وقوات الجيش باطلاق سراح
قيادات النظام السابق اذا
العناصر الاسلاميه داخل الجيش انا لا اتهم
كل الجيش الجيش ليس كله حركه اسلاميه
هنالك ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك جهات داخل
الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك جهات الضباط
اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراحه هذه
المجموعه نحن لدينا معلومات من داخل السجن
لحظه اطلاق النار لحظه اقتحام السجن لحظه
اطلاق سراحهم ولكن كانت قواتنا لم تكن
قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه ستعرف انه
الاتهام المضاد هو لكم انتم باقتحام
السجون
وبالتحرير هؤلاء
احنا منذ اليوم الاول اطلقنا راينا واضح
انما نواجه هو انقلاب بتخطيط من الحركه
الاسلاميه وقد عبرنا عن ذلك منذ اليوم
الاول هذه المساله هذه التجربه حد الهدى
وقد رحب بها المؤتمر الوطني في صفحته وعبر
عنها عدد من رموز المؤتمر الوطني وابواقي
في السوشيال ميديا محتفلين بهذا وكانوا
يدبرون معهد للعمليه الثانيه ما هي مصلحه
الدعم السريع في اطلاق عناصر النظام البيت
ما هي مصلحته في ذلك وهو يقاتل انقلاب
اصلا دبرته الحركه الاسلاميه هذا هذا حديث
يطلقونه هم
للتشويش لتغبيش الوعي بتاع الناس لكن
الشعب السوداني واعي والعالم واعي وقد عبر
احمد هارون بصراحه عن دعمه للجيش الجيش
الذي يقصده هو جيش الحركه الاسلاميه
وعناصر الحركه الاسلاميه لم يذكر البرهان
بل وصف ما حدث من اعياد القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع لثوره ديسمبر بالانقلاب
بمعنى
انه حتى الذي كان
رئيس مجلس اول مجلس السياده في في ذو
الحكومه الثوره انه انقلاب
للحازمي ثوره ديسمبر
على نفسه انت تقول انه جيش منقسم على نفسه
والبرهان لا يمثل كله وان البرهان جزء من
هذه من هذا من هذه الحركه الاسلاميه
الانقلابيه
نعم البرهان تامر مع الحركه الاسلاميه
الوهان تامر مع علي كرسي الحركه الاسلاميه
نفسها كلها ليست موحده الحركه الاسلاميه
لما
نتكلم يقودها الامين العام علي كرتي
واسامه عبد الله ومن معه من من الاخرين
هنالك اسلاميين
ليسوا طرفا لهذا وهنالك اسلاميين عبروا
بصوت واضح انهم ليسوا طرفا في انقلاب ولا
يدعمون العنف ولا يدعمون عوده النظام
النظامهم الا عبر الانتخابات هذا حديث
عبرت عنه وقيادات قبل من قبل
على العوده واعلن ذلك صراحه قال لن ننتظر
بعد هذا في رمضان هل لديكم معلومات هل
لديكم معلومات عن اماكن تواجد قيادات
النظام السابق وعلى راسهم عمر البشير
وبكري حسن صالح وعبد الرحيم محمد حسين حتى
الان لا تتواج لا تتوفر لدينا معلومات
يمكن الاستناد عليها ولكن كل الاستخبارات
الدعم السريع وكل كل قواته مجنده للبحث عن
هؤلاء والقبض عليهم لان هؤلاء فيهم
مطلوبين للمحكمه الجنائيه
مجرمين بصفتكم من تريدون القبض عليهم
اريد القبض على هذه المجموعه الهاربه من
السجن انتم قوات دعم سريع بصفتكم ماذا
تريدون القبض عليهم هناك جيش وهناك مجلس
سياده صح
يا عزيزي الان نحن نسيطر على كافه مداخل
ومخارج مدينه الخرطوم نسيطر على بحري
نسيطر على درمان نسيطر على الكباري نسيطر
على كل شيء لدينا مسؤوليه جهه شعبه
للسوداني لدينا مسؤوليه تجاه
الثوره السودانيه هؤلاء مجرمين
رفضهم الشعب السوداني علنا هؤلاء لديهم
جرائم ارتكبوا جرائم في دارفور مطلوبين
فيها للعداله انت ايضا
من هذا انتم جزء اساسي مما حصل في دارفور
ولو ليس هناك مذكرات دوليه بحقكم شخصيا او
بحق بعض القيادات الاخرى
يا عزيزي يختلف ان تقاتل حركات مسلحه تحمل
السلاح
او ان تقوم بحرق القرى نحن لسنا متهمين
قياده الدعم السريع ليست متهمه ولا في اي
مكان عبر حتى النازعين حتى كل الحركات
المسلحه لم تتهم قياده ماذا يقول كل
المحللين سياسيين الذين يظهرون معنا ولا
تاخذ الكلام عني ولكن عنهم يقولون قوات
الدعم السريع بدات هي الجنجويد في الاساس
وهي عماد النظام السابق والرئيس البشير في
كل ما حصل في دارفور وان النظام السابق هو
الذي كونها وانشاها والان انتم تقولون انه
نحن لسنا حركه اسلاميه والى ما هنالك كيف
هذا التناقض
يا اخي يا اخي دعني اقول لك شيء انت تعلم
ان الجفا الاسلامي او النظام الاسلامي قسم
المجتمع في دارفور الى عرب الى زرقه
الحركات المسلحه تكونت من مجموعات محدده
هنالك حرب قبليه طاحنه شجعها النظام هنالك
استقطاب هنالك
للحمل السلاح للدفاع عن النفس هنالك معارك
كثيره هذه مساله معدده يعلمها تعلمها كل
الجهات هذا هذا الواقع
افرز هو نحن الدعم السريع لم لم يولد قوه
زنجبيل الدعم السريع تاسست سنه 2013 هذا
هو قرار تاسيس التاريخ تاسيس الدعم السريع
نعم اسسوا القائد العام للجيش البشير
القائد الاعلى للجيش هذا معلوم ولكن هل
كان اسسه كقوه مؤدلجه هل اسسوا كقوه تتبع
للحركه الاسلاميه كما هي الامن الشعبي
وارتفاع الشعبي وغيره كل هذه القوه تتبع
للحركه الاسلاميه ومنظمه لكن الدعم السريع
لا قائده منظمه في الحركه الاسلاميه ولم
يكن يوما عضوا في المؤتمر الوطني كان
عسكريا صرفا بالتالي انتم الان ستحاربونهم
يعني اذا كان لهم دور عسكري او سياسي
ستحاربونهم وهم الان خارج السجون
التي دارت فيها الحرب نحن نعرف هم
يحاربوننا في الاعلام يحاربوننا على
الميدان كل الذين نحاربهم نحن لا نحارب
الجيش وقد اعلنا ذلك الجيش بريء الجيش
حراره مختطف الجيش يتعرض لمؤامره ولدينا
ما يثبت ذلك فلقد قلنا ذلك
ان ما نواجهه
هو وعودتهم الى السلطه هذا عبرنا عنه
بوضوح وخروجهم وبيانهم يؤكد ما نحن ذهبنا
اليه طيله هذه الفتره طيب احنا لم نقل ذلك
ممنهج وصحيفه سوداني الان تتحدث عن هروب
مئات النزلاء من سجن نياله الكبير بولايه
جنوب دارفور ما بعرف اذا عندك معلومات عن
هذا الموضوع يعني في معلومات
ليس لدي اي معلومات اذا كان هذا الامر
ممنهج استاذ يوسف شو بده يكون تداعياته
وموقفكم بالتالي يعني هل تتصورون بانه
هناك تحضير لما هو اكبر في الايام القادمه
من خلال قياده هؤلاء لعمليه سياسيه جديده
مختلفه كليا عن كل مخرجات ثوره
يا اخي يا اخي هؤلاء لفظهم الشعب السودان
ولن يقبلهم الشعب السوداني ولن يقبلون
الزوار ديسمبر ولن تقبلهم القوه المدنيه
السياسيه ولن يقبلهم العالم لانهم مطلوبين
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولديهم جرائم
معروفه هذه هذه النظام بايت هذه قيادات
استهلكت هذه قيادات ليس لديها جديد تقدمه
حكمت 30 سنه ضاق الشعب الامرين من حكمهم
الشعب ليس في الخرطوم وحده في الخرطوم
فتحت السجون والمعتقلات وتشريد الشعب
ذاكرته حيه لم تنقص اربع سنوات لحكمهم في
دارفور النازحين واللاجئين في شركه الشهد
في جبال النوبه ما زال الناس يتذكرون
اصوات ما داله في النيل الازرق في كجبار
في في الشهداء العارفون هذا هذه ذاكره حيه
لا يمكن ان يقفز عليها لا يمكن ان يجدوا
سنه شعبي لا يمكن ان تنحاز لهم اي قوه
سياسيه هؤلاء هذه قيادات لا عشره ايام
ونحن نعلم حرقهم ولم ينتصروا في اي معركه
يقول انه الوضع مستقر وانت تقول انه
تسيطرون على مداخل ومخارج الخرطوم
والسودان بلد كبير جدا يعني والولايات
كلها مستقره ليس فيها اخبار عن اشتباكات
او اقتتال وبالتالي انتم ليس لديكم
اي موطئ قدم فيها
يا اخي نحن حين نقول كلمه يسمعها شعبنا
قناتك الان التي تذيع مفتوحه في كل البيوت
السودانيه لا يمكن ان نكذب على الشعب
السوداني ولا يمكن ان نقود اعلامي
وانتصارات وهميه في في قنوات التلفزيون
نحن نسيطر نحن موجودين في الشارع موجودين
في الاذاعه والتلفزيون موجودين في القسم
موجودين في صياد العامه موجودين في مطار
الخرطوم موجودين في كل الكباري المؤديه
منه الى المدن الثلاث نحن موجودين وي
شعبنا ذلك يمرون بنا كل يوم اثناء الهدنه
اليوم مرت الاف الناس عبر الكباري التي
تسيطر عليه وعبر الطرقات مرتده دبلوماسيه
خارجه نحن لا نكذب هذا هذه مسؤوليه نحن لا
نكسب ما الذي يدعونا ان نكذب وندعي بطولات
ليست لنا هذا هذا واقع موجود وشعبنا يعلم
انه موجود
ومن يكذب ذلك
في الفضائيات وفي الانترنت وكذا لكن هذا
واقع موجود على الارض طب بس خططكم
المقال ثلاثه موضوع كذب في عوامل الحرب
نفسيه بتلعب دورها الكل بيعرف هذا الموضوع
من العادي جدا بانه يصير من الطرفين ولكن
الان شو خططكم يعني في هدنه بعد باقي منها
مثلا يومين ماذا ستفعلون
يا اخي هذه الهدنه الهدف منها هدف انسان
هنالك معاناه انسانيه في المدن ليس في
الخرطوم وحده حتى في المدن الاخرى في
الولايات هنالك معاناه انسانيه طاحنه هذه
المعانه الانسانيه تتطلب تعامل جات هنالك
الجثث ملقاه في الشوارع في كل الخرطوم
تحللت هنالك قضايا بيئيه هناك قضايا
انسانيه هنالكهرباء مقطوعه هنالك مياه
مقطوعه في بحري نحن التزمنا بالهدنه
الاسلاميه الهدنه
الانسانيه لصالح شعبنا لصالح مواطنين
ونلتزم بها وستنظل نلتزم بها بعد ذلك لكل
يعني جزء كبير شريحه كبيره من السودانيين
لعلها تقول الان ردا عليك بانه انتم يعني
تسنون الحرب ومن ثم تمنون علينا
بهدنه لثلاثه ايام كي نزل قتلانه عن
الشوارع
يا اخي هذه الحرب تم اطلاقها يعلم الجميع
من تم اطلاقها من هاجمت الصباح يوم 15
الدعم السريع في مقراتي من اعلن حل الدعم
السريع من اعلنت الدعم السريع هو متمرده
ويجب طردها وضربها من ابلغ الحرب نحن لم
نطلق الحرب نحن نحن واجهنا الحرب دفاعا عن
النفس هذا الانقلاب رتب له قيادات في
الجيش وقيادات في الحركه الاسلاميه
الهدف الاساسي من القضاء على الدرب
بضربه
اذا انت
التحرك ومن الحركه الاسلاميه في الجيش
والى ما هنالك يعني سينقلب على نفسه يعني
لماذا يقول تحقق لماذا يقود الانقلاب هو
رئيس مجلس السياده هو قائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه نفسه ليس الانقلاب على نفسه
الانقلاب على عمليه سياسيه كامله احنا
ظللنا لشهور نعمل في عمليه سياسيه بموجبه
يخرج الجيش
يجب تفكيك التمكين التمكين الحركه
الاسلاميه في الجيش بشكل معلن اصلاح الجيش
بشكل كامل اصلاح كل المنظومه الامنيه
البرهان نفسه يجب ان يوقع يوم 1/4 على
خروجه من السلطه خرج في اخر ورشه للاصلاح
الامني انسحب تم سحب الجيش نحن كنا
موجودين حتى نهايه الورشه داخل قاعه
الصداقه هذا الانقلاب على عمليه سياسيه
كانت ستؤسس لسلطه مدنيه كانت تحاسبا
الحاربين بمال الشعب للتمكين كل هذه هذا
ذاكره غريبه قبل شهر كل شيء كان معدل
جاهزا ل
هل انتم مستعدون لتمديد الهدنه
اذا كانت لصالح شاحنه واذا كانت في صالح
المواطنين لا يوجد لا يوجد شيء الان لا
توجد مواجهات حقيقيه بين الجيش على الارض
صالح المواطنين بدون شك هل انتم عسكريا
وسياسيا مستعدون لتمديد الهدنه
بعد انتهاء الهدنه اذا التزم بها الطرف
الاخر اذا كانت هنالك سيطره حقيقيه على
الجيش لان اليوم الجيش خرج الهدنه في اكثر
من موقع هنالك طياره ضربت في الصالحه
هنالك هجوم على قواتنا في هنالك هجوم واسع
يبدو ان الجيش ليس لديه زياده مركزيه
تسيطر عليه بقيادته تعلن الاربع هدنات
التي تمت يخرجها الجيش عل
نا يبدو ان قياده الجيش لا تسيطر والا
انها ترابط او تعلي موقف وتعمل الجيش اذا
كانت هنالك حول لماذا لماذا انت تتهم
ضباطا في الجيش باختطاف قرار عبد الفتاح
البرهان
فالجيش باختطاف قرار عبد الفتاح البرهان
منذ
اليوم هو
رهينه لقرار الحركه الاسلاميه والضباط
الاسلاميين في الجيش البرهان قرار الجيش
نفسه والجيش ليس كله هنالك ضباط شرفاء
هنالك جنود هنالك صغار ضباط ليس الجيش كله
في يد الحركه الاسلاميه ولكن بقرار الجيش
القوه القيادات قيادات العليا في الجيش
هذه القيادات
فاسده تريد المحافظه على مصالحها تريد ان
تستمر في مواقعها لا تريد ان تسلم شركات
الجيش هنالك مصالح ضاربه كل هؤلاء يختطف
في هذه المعرفه الان تحدث اليكم
الامريكيون اليوم وفي هذه الايام عموما
مجلس الامن القومي وغيرهم ما الذي دار في
الاتصالات مع الامريكيين
نعم للامريكيين اهتمام بالغ
العمليه وقت العمليات باعاده المسار
المدني في الديموقراطي باعاده العمليه
السياسيه حتى بامكان بشكل جديد نحن لا
نرفض ان تعود ان يعود الشعب السوداني
اللي اتخذ قراره بيده نعتقد ان الامريكيين
به التصورات حتى الان غير غير مكتمله نحن
على تواصل معهم
غير المكتمل كما تصفه الذي طرحه عليكم
الامريكيون
ليس لديهم مبادره واضحه كلما ما ما يرجونه
الان التوصل لوقفه اطلاق النار بعدها
التفكير في عمليه سياسيه حتى الان ليس
لديهم مقترح واضح هل عرضوا عليكم ارسال
مراقبين دوليين
حتى الان لم يعرضوا علينا ذلك مراقبين
دوليين دون توصل لوقف اغلاق نار له معنا
طبعا بعد التوصل اطلاق نار ولكن انتم
مستعدون لذلك هل انتم تقبلون
بمراقبين دوليين هل لكم اشتراطات معينه
لجهه جنسياتهم واليات عملهم
هذه مساله يمكن النقاش حول لان
نوظف النار مع من نتفاوض مع من هذا سؤال
كبير جدا مطروح امامنا امام امام القوات
المسلحه هل نوقف مع ضباط مؤتليين او مع
علي كرسي او مع البرهان نفسه هل البرهان
يمتلك القرار الان هذه اسئله لازم
الاجابات قبل ان الاجابه على هكذا اذا
كانت هذه الاحزاب التي تتهمها بالانقلاب
موجوده على طاوله التفاوض بما انها جزء من
المشكله كما تقول لابد ان تكون جزءا من
الحل اليس كذلك الم تقبلوا بها على طاوله
التفاوض
لن نقبل في طاوله التفاوض مع الحركه
الاسلاميه مطلقه انت نقاتلهم وسنستمر في
قتالهم لن نقبل معهم لان هذه قوه مع الجيش
اولا تقبلونها مع الجيش اولا للتوصل الى
حل عسكري ومن ثم الانتقال الى حل سياسي
تجلسون مع البرهان
لا نقبلها نحن لا نقبل اي شروط من قوه
سياسيه تم اسقاطها من قبل ولا اي
حوار مع اشخاص مؤدبين الجيش فيه شرفاء
الجيش فيه ضباط لديهم مواقف معلنه لا يمكن
ابدا ان يختطف قرارهم يعودوا عبر التفاوض
الى
انتم تنحي البرهان اولا قبل البدء باي
مفاوضات
البرهان لا يملك شيء الان هو عمليا لا
يملك شيء
حضراتكم تؤيدون التفاوض مع تدعونا الى
تنحيته او الى تنحيه تنحيه قبل الدخول في
طاوله التفاوض مع الجيش
البرهان هو قائد العام للجيش هل يمتلك
القدره على وقف اطلاق النار هل يمتلك
القدره على التوقيع نيابه عن الجيش هذا
تثبته الايام القادمه
البرهان لا يملك شيء
انتم الان عندما يتحدث اليكم الامريكيون
مثلا او اي قياده دوليه من الرباعيه دوليه
مثلا لن تقول لهم يعني مثل هذا الكلام
بالنتيجه في حتى لو اتهمتم البرهان بما
تتهمونه به هناك دعوات لوقف اطلاق النار
هناك تنسيق سيكون مع الجيش قائد الجيش
الان هو عبد الفتاح البرهان بالتالي انتم
ستتفاوضون معه على ماذا
نحن لم نوافق ولم تطرح علينا اسئله على من
التفاوض نحن الان نناقش هذا الامر داخليا
ونناقشه مع اطراف عديده داخليه البرهان
حسب مجريات الاحداث في الايام السابقه لا
يملك قرار الجيش ونحن نعلم من يوجه
العمليات ومن يديرها ونتعلم
لا لا الجيش الان هنالك اكثر من 470
من اسره في المعارك او سلمون انفسهم طوعا
هؤلاء
كم عدد الضباب
انت تقول بانه 437 ضابط من الجيش السوداني
انشقوا وباتوا في صفوفكم
اسروا اسر عدد كبير منهم في المعارك نحن
عرضناهم في التلفزيون في السوشيال ميديا
عبر الفيديوهات وبعضهم سلم نفسه طوعا
واعلن ذلك في فيديوهات منشوره في السوشيال
ميديا ضبارهم العسكريه برتبهم معلومه
سلموا انفسهم وارتكازات الدعم السريع
والاف الجن
ود لحتى مو سلموا انفسهم هذا واقع موجود
في الارض
يعني شاهدنا كثيرا من ذلك ولكن هذا تحت
قوه سلاح يعني
في اسرع انا لا انكر هنالك اسره في
المعاركوا اسرى كثيرين جدا من الضباط في
فيهم الدعم السريع واعلن عنهم وعاملهم
معامله
ما تقتضيه معامله الاسرى ولكن هنالك ضباط
ايضا سلموا نفسهم للدعم السريع طبعا
ورفضوا الحرب ورفضوا استمرار الحرب من
اراد منهم ان يذهب الى بيته من اراد ان يخ
اطب اسرته نحن لا نمنعه كل من سلم نفسه
طوعا من حقي يعني يقلع يقلع الكاكي ويسدم
س
لاحه نحن ليس لدينا عداوه مع الجيش الجيش
واخواننا الجيش
ولا نقتلهم ولا المفروض انتم جزء من الجيش
وليس الجيش جزء منكم استاذ يوسف
هذه مساله الان امام نحن امام واقع جديد
الان يجب تاسيس جيش واحد غير مؤدب لا لا
داعي لوجود جيوش متعدده في السودان ونحن
وقعنا على ذلك في الاستفاده الايطالي وكان
عليه في العمليه السياسيه التي كانت جاريه
نحن ندعو للجيش الواحد لكن لا ندعو للجيش
تسيطر عليه اي حركه اي ايدولوجيا اي
معلومات حاليا عن تململ في داخل صفوف
قيادات الجيش السوداني
يا اخي يا هنالك مخالفه للتعليمات هنالك
انسحاب من المعارك
عدم رغبه في القتال هنالك الغاء السلاح
شهدنا الكثير خلال العشره ايام الماضيه
الجيش ليس لديه رغبه مقاتله الدعم السريع
الجيش لا ينظر للدعم السريع انه عدو حين
نقول الجيش نقول الجيش غير المؤدل حتى
الجنود ليس لديهم رغبه في مقاتله وليس حتى
اي لحظه رغم انه الناطق الرسمي للجيش
وغيرهم يصفنا بالعدو ولكن نحن لم نصف
الجيش بالعدوى لان الجيش السوداني مؤسسه
قوميه تم اختطافها من 89 تم تنفيذها جلده
الحركه الاسلاميه بها نحن لا ننظر للجيش
انه عدو الجيش جيش جيش السودان وليس جيش
الكيزان وليس جيش البرهان الجيش جيش
السودانيين ابناء الشعب السوداني هم الذين
اقاموا في هذه الحرب اذا نحن لا ننظر
للجيش انه عدو ولا حتى الان معركتنا ليست
مع الجيش السوداني ما هي دعوتكم لضباط
وجنود الجيش السوداني الان
نحن
نقول لجهودات الجيش نحن لا نهاجمهم ولا
نسعى لقتالهم نحن ارتكز في المواقع
الاستراتيجيه التي سيطرنا عليها المدن
لحمايه نفسنا في الطرقات لحمايه نفسنا لم
نبادر بقتالهم وليس ولم نفكر يوما من
الايام طيله تاريخ الدعم السريع طيله
الازمه السياسيه التي مرت بها البلاد
بفتره الماضيه لم نفكر ولم نخطط ابدا
لقتال الجيش السوداني فوجئنا بالحرب يوم
15 ابريل وجينا بها بالطائرات تضرب
معسكراتنا وبيوتنا كل شيء
يستهدفون ارتكازاتنا كلها هذا حدث في يوم
وهذه لا تخص الشعب السوداني بل تخص تنظيم
محدد تنظيم استغل الجيش وحكم
ذات الاداه للعوده الى السلطه فالعقبه
التي تقف امامهم هي الدعم السريع واراد
التخلص منها بعمليه خاصه وفشل وتم فشل
الانقلاب وتم فشل كل شيء العمليه الوحيده
التي نج
بر ليس هنالك اي عمليه ناجحه اخرى ويجب ان
يفهم الجيش انه ليس لديه مصلحه السوداني
مصلحه في هكذا قتال
طيب الان اعود الى النقطه الاساسيه التي
كنا نتحدث عنها استاذ يوسف بشان عمر
البشير وقياداته هناك معلومات ترد اتاكد
الان بعدما وردت قبل قليل من انه عمر
البشير مع
قياديين اخرين كانوا اصلا في المستشفى
العسكري منذ فتره ولم يهرب من السجن او
يهربوا هل هذه معلوماتكم ايضا
يا اخي انا حسب المعلومات التي لدي انهم
كانوا داخل السجن هذه المعلومات انهم
كانوا داخل السجن هنالك
الراي انهم كانوا في مستشفى عاليه وغيرها
هذه معلومات غير مؤكده ولكن نحن لدينا
كل السجناء علي عثمان محمد طه نافع كل
السجناء الذين تم تهريبهم كانوا داخل
السجن وتم تحدي حتى عمر البشير وبكري حسن
صالح وعبد الرحيم محمد حسين
هذه المعلومات التي المتوفره التي
وهربوا من قبل
جماعتهم في الخارج
نعم وهربوا باطلاق نار وهنالك عساكر
اصيبوا في هذه المتر هناك سجناء اخرين
هل حاولت قوات الدعم السريع منع ذلك هل
كانت على درايه دامت سريع تم ابلاغه من من
من عساكر عسكري في السجون بعد بعد العمليه
ان هنالك تمت عمليه كذا كذا وحين تحركت
قوات الدعم السريع لقد كانت العمليه قد
تمت ونفذت ليس لدينا علم مسبق بالعمليه
وتوقيتاتها هذه عمليه دبرتها استخبارات
عسكريه لا نعلم
الخرطوم الا السجون
نحن لم نحرث السجود لان السجون المسؤوليه
الشرطه وحتى الان الشرطه ليست طرفا في في
صراع الدائره الشرطه تلتزم الحياد مع
الشرطه تقوم بواجباته ومسؤولياتها نحن لا
نحرث السجون وليس لدينا اي مهام في السجون
ولا ولا ولا تتقاطع مهام يعني انتم يعني
يعني الهدف من تحرككم كله انتم تتهمون
الجيش كله وتقاتلون الجيش كله بغض النظر
عما اذا كان منقسما او لا يعني والان
تعترف بالشرطه على حدا وتريد لها ان تقوم
بواجباتها
الشرطه لا تتعرض فيها من قواتنا لاي اي اي
اعتداء ولا من الجيش هناك ما زالت هنالك
مغارات تقوم بحمايتها الشرطه غير هذا
هنالك مواقع اخرى غير السجون تحرسها
الشرطه وما زال تمارس معها الشرطه
السودانيه شرطه قديمه وشرطه مدربه شرطه
موجوده تقوم بمهامه نحن لا نستطيع او نعلن
نفسنا بديلا للشرطه نحن نعلن نفسنا لحمايه
المدنيين من من من اي اعتداء في المناطق
التي نسيطر عليها
قواتنا في تواجه حرب تؤمن مداخل المدن نحن
في حاله دفاعيه ولكن كيف تنقل بعد ذلك هم
من المفترض انهم توجهوا عندما هربوا من
السجن من المفترض انهم ذهبوا الى جهه امنه
اين كانت قوات الدعم السريع التي تقول
انها تسيطر على الكباري وعلى الطرقات وعلى
المداخل والمخارج
هذه القوه لم تعبر اي كبري من كباري من
الكباري الذين دبروا هذه العمليه خططوا
وهنالك في الجهات
دائما نحن الاستخبارات العسكريه في الجيش
دبرت لهذه العمليه لا ندري ليس لدينا
معلومات كامله عن كيف كيفيه اخراجهم لا
نعرف هل تم انزال جوي داخل السجن لا نعرف
ليس لديه معلومات حقيقيه ولكن هذه العمليه
يعني
او هناك امكانيه لان يكون حدث ذلك فعلا
لانزال الجوي
نعم يمكن يمكن ان تنزل طائره عموديه
والاغلاق بهم هذه عمليه
بناء على معلومه غير مؤكده او بناء على
تحليل لا هذا تحليل هذا توقعات انا لا ليس
لدي معلومه عن كيفيه تنفيذ العمليه او
كيفيه اخلاقه من السجن اؤكد لك هذا هذا
مجرد توقعات او احتمالات
هل انتم منوط بكم الان هل تعتبرون جزءا من
واجبكم الان البحث والتحري عنهم واعاده
ضبطهم من جديد
هنالك اشخاص اخرين متهمين في جرائم قتل
هنالك اشخاص اخرين اجرموا في حق الشعب
السوداني طوال 30 سنه نحن من مسؤوليتنا
وفي اطار حربنا
والتي يواجهوننا بها من مسؤوليتنا وسنسعى
لغرضهم سنسعى بكل ما يمكن ان نقبض القبض
عليهم هؤلاء
وسط هذا هذا اذا وصلت اياديكم الى عمر
البشير وعبد الرحمن عبد الرحيم محمد حسين
واحمد هارون المطلوبين للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه تسلمونهم
تسلمهم سلطه بعد تشكيل سلطه نحن الان لسنا
سلطه سياسيه تحكم البلد لسنا انقلابيين
الشعب السوداني يقرر مصيرهم هذا ليس قرار
يتخذها يتخذه الدعم السريع منفردا ولكن
سنحتفظ الى حين يقرر الشعب السوداني في
مصيرهم يعني تقول لست منقابيين لو كان نجح
تحرك اليوم الاول الم يكن حميتي ليقرا
البيان رقم واحد
اذا اراد ان يقرا البيار رقم واحد لغراه
في اليوم الثاني هو الاول لا يوجد شيء
اكثر على القصر الجمهوري والاذاعه
والتلفزيون كل الانقلابات لم تفعل ذلك لم
تستطيعوا ان تفعلوا ذلك في الواقع اليس
كذلك لماذا ما الذي يمنعني اذا كنا سلطه
انقلابيه ما الذي واضح على الاذاعه
والتلفزيون على المطار وعلى القصر وعلى
القياده العامه هذا لم يحصل
نحن الان موجودين في هذه المواقع نهائيا
جزئيا جزئيه
هنالك القياده نحن الان نسيطر على الجزء
جزء كبير من مبادئها ومبانيها هنالك فقط
مبنى واحد فيه غناصه وبدروم وحراسات
وهذا بعد ان تفتح الاجواء بعد ان نستطيع
التامين وصول الصحفيين كله هو العالم كله
سيعرف ما نتحدث عنه باي مكان يعني القياده
كبيره فيها خمس مباني عن يعني لو اكيد مش
راح تعطينا احداثيات موقعك موقعكم ولكن
يعني على الاقل بعض التفاصيل لكي يصدق
الشعب السوداني ذلك او لا يا اخي نحن
صورنا نحن نقلنا نقلنا صور حيه من داخل
مكتب كباشي ومن داخل
مكتب
هاشم ياسر العطا كل هذه صور حيه نغنوا
وسائق تدين صحفيين كانوا يتلقون رواتب
نشرت ولم يتم غنى صور حيه من داخل القياده
العامه ولكن الصور مش كانت من الاخر الصور
كانت من القصر اللي طلعتوها لا من داخل
القياده العامه
يا اخي نحن انا قلت لك ان هنالك بدرو
هنالك مباني تحت الارض في القياده العامه
نحن نحن لا نتحدث الان عن اين يوجد
البرهان او اين هو لا نتحدث عن هذا ولكن
اذا البرهان موجود في القياده العامه
فليخرج يخاطب الشعب من امام مباني القياده
العامه فليخرج فليخرج الكتاب حتى ان كان
بصوره بالتلفون هذا هذا هذا واقع موجود من
اول يوم شو معلوماتكم عن مكان تواجده اذا
نحن لا نفتح معلوماتنا نحن نتابع نحن نعمل
تتبع على لمواقعه اذا كنا
تحديد مكانه بالضبط لما انتظرنا لماذا لا
تقولون هذا الكلام ايضا لانفسكم اين سيد
حميدتي
طيب
ولكن يعني ليس باستطاعته على ما يبدو ان
يخرج في خطاب من مكان امن مستقر ذات هيئه
سياديه
هو يتفقد قواته داخل القصر الجمهوري هذا
هذا هذا هدف لهذه الى هناك ويتفقد قواته
في اي موقع ويتحرك من موقع لموقع اخر بشكل
دائم ويقود قواتي ويوجهها ولا يدير
المعرفه في الخرطوم
لم يحدث لم يحدث
لا
لا بشكل مباشر ولا بشكل غير مباشر بمعنى
انه تعرض لقصف مثلا او لا لم يتعرض لاي
محاوله اغتيال طيله الايام الماضيه
قياداته المقربه ايضا
جميع قيادات الدعم السريع المقربه سواء
كانت مدنيه وعسكريه بسلام وبامان
وماذا عن الدور الذي يقوم به شقيقه الان
شقيقه الدعم السريع فنحن نعلم
مهام عملياتيه في قياده هذه المعركه
نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع من
الخرطوم تحياتي اليك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات